MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Cloud migration
is top of mind for many
organizations today.
While moving to the cloud
can be full of challenges,
the cloud offers many advantages
around increased agility,
new and innovative services,
and on-demand pricing
that traditional data
centers don't offer.
So let's talk about one way
to make migration easier--
hosting your native
VMware environment right
on Google Cloud.
The reality is that managing
your own infrastructure
is often an unnecessary
burden and usually
isn't a differentiator
for the business.
While migrating to the
cloud is the end goal,
there can be significant
complexity in refactoring
applications, as well as
the tools and policies
your teams use.
The challenge of migration
can involve risks
and put your business
in analysis paralysis.
Google Cloud wants to
help businesses capture
the benefits of cloud while
reducing the complexity
of doing a full refactor.
Today we're going
to show you how
that's possible with
Google Cloud VMware
Engine, a fast and safe
way to move your VMware
workloads to the cloud.
Google Cloud VMware
Engine is built
to address the
biggest issues that
prevent most workloads
from moving to the cloud--
lack of resources and the
cost of re-architecting apps.
With Google Cloud VMware Engine,
you can migrate your apps
with zero changes.
You'll be able to run your
VMs in a private native VMware
environment.
This means you can use the same
tools, processes, and policies
while still getting
the advantages of being
in the cloud, on top of deeper
integration with other Google
Cloud services.
In fact, it doesn't take long
to spin up an environment.
You can lower your
total cost of ownership
quickly and spend
more time planning how
to re-architect down the road.
Let's walk through a demo of how
to set up a Google Cloud VMware
environment with
just a few clicks.
We'll start by showing how to
access the Google Cloud VMware
Engine from the
Google Cloud console.
After that, we'll create a
secure and isolated boundary
called a private cloud that will
contain the VMware environment.
Then we'll take a tour of
some of the platform features
and jump into the familiar
vSphere interface.
Let's start with the icon in
the upper left-hand corner
of the console.
Scroll down to the
Compute section,
and you'll see VMware Engine.
Clicking on this takes
us to the overview
page, which provides
additional details
and lets us do
common operations,
like creating our private
cloud, viewing documentation,
launching the vSphere client,
modifying network settings,
and managing users.
Let's create a private cloud by
clicking on the Create Private
Cloud button.
Here we'll be able to
customize our cloud
by choosing a location.
Let's leave it on US east and
increase the number of nodes
from 3 to 4.
We'll also add a CIDR
range for our appliances
and then click
Review and Create.
After reviewing that
everything looks good,
we'll click Create to
kick off the process.
Once completed, we can see
the details of the environment
as well as other private
clouds that we've created.
While the private
cloud is being created,
let's talk about pricing.
Pricing is done per node and
includes all the storage,
compute, and licensing to
run a VMware environment.
By default, you'll
pay per month,
but you can also sign up
for a one or three-year plan
to save money.
All of the billing
for VMware Engine
is integrated so you
can see payment details
side by side with your
other Google Cloud services.
After your private
cloud is created,
you can access it from
the Resources screen.
Here you can see all of your
private clouds and manage them.
By clicking on a
specific private cloud,
you can see the details
of its configuration.
Here you can launch your
VirtualCenter client,
which is the standard enterprise
VirtualCenter client you're
likely already familiar with.
You can also expand the cloud
by adding nodes, as well
as scrolling down
to the bottom, where
you can shrink your environment,
escalate your privileges so you
can get admin access
in VirtualCenter,
or even delete the
private cloud entirely.
Let's scroll back up to
the top of the screen
and launch the vSphere client.
On this login page, we
can enter our credentials.
After logging in, you
can see that we're
working with the same interface
that you and your team
are likely already
familiar with.
This native access to VMware
gives you a standard way
to control your applications
while getting all the benefits
of running on Google Cloud.
Now let's return to the Google
Cloud VMware Engine management
console and look at some
of the networking details.
Here we can manage and set up
our VLANs and subnets, firewall
tables, public IP addresses,
VPN gateways, and VPC Peerings,
where you can easily access
your Google Cloud infrastructure
from your VMware environment.
The activities interface
provides details
that your security
and operations
teams will be interested in.
It provides any alerts that have
occurred in the environment,
details on any events that
have occurred in the past,
current running
tasks, and allows
you to audit any
activities done by a user.
The Account screen gives you an
overview of your entire VMware
Engine environment,
including the ability
to sign up for email alerts.
You're also able to
manage the users who
have access to the environment.
We're eager for everyone to
see Google Cloud VMware Engine
and are excited to say
that it's available for you
to try out right now.
With this quick
tour, you should be
ready to migrate your VMware
environment to the cloud
quickly.
Check out the documentation
and see more details
and spin up your
own private cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]